as many people in this room probably do
know Raphael and W guys have known each
other for decades decade how long has
this film been in gestation and what was
the germ of the idea that feels like a
Jess question I think that's it that's
it well Jess is the one who kind of
discovered Raphael on YouTube so yeah go
ahead take a Ches
[Laughter]
they all know I'm super super shy so
this is their ribbon-like talk talk
of course her to speak all the time so
if you have questions please address
we're not allowed to ask you a question
as the Academy doesn't allow that so I
guess I've I've always been really
excited about the idea of trying to do
something different with the musical
kind of genre and I had this idea like
wouldn't it be really cool if instead of
when the characters are overwhelmed with
emotion that they burst into verse and
sit instead of song and what would that
be like and so I sort of just did sort
of like a deep dive on the internet and
I came across an amazing poet Raphael
Cassell who at that time was the
youngest poet on HBO Def Poetry Jam and
he a lots of clips on YouTube and I just
became like a stalker and I like watched
every single pump poem and they were all
amazing and I just took a leap of faith
and I reached out and I sent him an
email saying this is gonna sound crazy
and I know you're a poet but is there
any way you would think about trying to
translate what you do in that and that
then that type of writing and into a
film and I was super excited when he
wrote me back and so like yeah I'd
really love to explore that and so we
spent about a year with Keith trying to
figure out like what that could could be
and along along that time he has he sent
me a beautiful poem that he had written
called monster which was all about how
you know devastating it was that so many
of his friends
we're dying such tragic deaths in
Auckland I think that because it became
sort of a little bit of a germ and then
we were lucky enough to do an event for
a documentary called Thunder soul which
Rafa was unable to go to and he set his
amazing best friend
daveed Diggs instead for everybody
involved Rafa couldn't make and Degas
blew us away like within you know
because he's himself he is amazing and
you know we quickly before I bus were
like yeah you know what the movie should
be is just all four of us trying to
figure it out
Raphael was film in your head as a
possible genre you wanted to explore at
that point when Jess contacted you want
absolutely I don't think I don't know
that we there isn't that industry
doesn't exist in the in the Bay Area
that sort of that feels like such a
fantastical idea that you would ever be
able to make a film of a story that you
were that you were dreaming about and so
I think we would we would think about
long-form stories but we really think
about the more in terms of theatre or
other sort of a more immediate
immediately available resources so - I
mean to us that that when we were you
know we were late teens early 20s at
that point this felt Justin Keith were
the biggest producers we never heard of
the Vino that were that were there were
within content you know so we were so
dead set on just trying to live up to
what they were what they were seeing in
me and then and then eventually seeing
in us
I was I was we were shooting like web
series stuff and music videos and I was
doing like a lot of post productions
that worked but this is all sort of very
small and localized as I think the brain
was working in terms of story in that
way but it really took what ended up
being years of development with them -
to both realize for ourselves and to
realize ourselves as screenwriters and
also to figure out sort of what how to
make some of those
being developed in other relevant spaces
applied to to this medium to be were you
at first like hello I'm a future Tony
and Grammy award-winner like he's been
saying where am I here's and it's been
so annoying
and now it now it's now he's got it and
he just won't shut up quiet rather when
you have statues you can talk now no no
man I was a [ __ ] substitute teacher
like and yeah and then I was like
sleeping on subway cars in New York when
when I met Keith and Jes cuz I you know
made the pilgrimage with some friends
down to Obama's inauguration which is
where we actually spent a day going to
maroon 5 concert yes so that's why we're
all wearing maroon today yeah yeah this
is deep cut guys weren't trying to blend
in with the background didn't know
what's gonna happen they're trying to
feel like we belong sorry for all your
pictures 5 that's very new Oakland it's
it's no part of Oakley sorry no yeah no
I I wasn't thinking any of those things
I was mostly concerned with like eating
and and making rap songs which is what
you know Ralph and I really started
working at because he was running a
studio in North Oakland when I came back
from college and we like stayed up one
night making rap songs all night and
that was it that was like oh this is
what I do now this is who I work with on
everything right those rap songs went so
well we should probably you know write
plays it seemed like a logical thing at
the time but yeah so I when this came
along it was again it was mostly like
the first few years of this were really
us trying to impress them like
drue like driving down to LA and like
pretending we had hotel rooms because we
were totally adult and then like
sleeping in a car wreck but you know
like driving the whole way down being
like what is it how do you how do you
write what is stage direction in a
screenplay what does that look like yeah
and Justin Keys really just pretending
that they didn't know we had no idea
what we were doing and be like giving us
scripts to read of me like why did you
guys read this just you know cuz they're
things that we like us being like oh
yeah totally we could look at these
because among all of the other scripts
were reading and writing right now we
might as well like we'll add them to the
pouch sure you guys like these great
we'll send you some that we like to but
what you know what they were doing
really was artists development and being
very kind about it but you know spending
ten years with us like trying to teach
us how to do a thing and also all four
of us sort of working together to figure
out how to do something that none of us
really knew how to do like how to bring
in art form that we were very versed in
and figure out how to make it look
natural on a on its screen Keith when
you think back to this whole process did
the development of the screenplay happen
more easily or more was it more
difficult of a process than you imagined
it would be I would say was the longer
process then I think any of us imagined
it would be but it I think it I don't
think it was ever difficult in the way
the development sometimes is like I
think we all very very early on knew we
all wanted to make the same movie as
each other and a lot of the times that
development feels the most difficult is
when you either never realize you're all
trying to make a different thing or you
know you're all trying to make a
different thing from each other and
stuck working together this was really
pleasurable the whole time just because
we all knew from the very beginning what
we wanted to make and it was just about
carving away the stuff that wasn't that
it's super impressive that Carlos Lopez
Estrada this is his first feature film
as a director I mean that's extremely
impressive how did you guys land on him
I think you guys had a history together
with some music video
and how did you get Jess and Keith on
board for bringing him on yeah I mean I
I met Carlos doing clipping music videos
from my band clipping that were way
overreaching I mean what we knew about
Carlos is he always does more with with
what is available you know that we knew
that going in and and really that was
seven or eight years ago and since then
I've clippings worked with him a bunch
more Ralph and I have worked with him
and and all three of us have worked
together on some things the story about
ecology tell the story of how Carlos and
it oh yeah we the three of us were
having a mean Justin Keith are having a
meeting in New York we sort of knew that
there was an upcoming window where where
Diggs was gonna be available to do a
longer stretch of shoot this 22 days
that we had and so we were sort of just
trying to reverse engineer from there we
knew we had to do a page one rewrite we
knew we had to get going as soon as
possible and and we started sort of
talking about well you know what what
how would we want it how would we want
to do this and they asked if I there was
anybody that I that I thought should
direct and I immediately thought of
Carlos because we we knew that what this
was gonna take was somebody that we had
an easy shorthand with that was going to
be able to take in a story that's so
site-specific and respected enough to
make this a truly collaborative
experience going forward because it was
gonna require constant communication in
real time to make sure that it felt
authentic right the thing we needed to
ensure more more than anything so we're
telling a hometown story of a place
where people will then see it and and
grade it based on and whether or not it
feels honest and sincere to the place
and so we knew that Carlos is a very
he's a very careful director he's a very
very loving director and and we're big
advocates for as we learned from Jess
and Keith to to believe in people and
and and when they have a we have an
opportunity to hand forward like it's
very hard to get your first film I mean
we thought of Carlos
well this is somebody who's ready to
that we know is ready to do it and that
it's gonna work with us and in a way
that we feel like is most conducive
towards getting getting a very ambitious
idea executed well and the other big
thing was we were working at a W and I
started this program at the Public
Theater in New York called bars which is
a theatre and verse workshop and it has
a thank you for that one person clipped
it's a it's a workshop that that's just
examining the intersection of theater
and ver and heightened language and
there's an end video project that we do
every time that's that's sort of like
filmed in front of a live audience and
it's this big one-take thing and Carlos
really created that for us and we've
done it we've done it a few times with
him and a lot of that was an
investigation on how to capture verse
that is traditionally in the theatre
into film and transform put it on
YouTube it did very well and so we were
like well this is somebody also who's
gone as far down the the experiment so a
rabbit hole in this medium as anyone
else let's let's like we've been doing
let's elevate one at one of our peers
along with us into this opportunity
let's band together and let's let's try
to see if we can solve this riddle
together hi jumpin really quick and just
say that another thing that that was so
appealing about having someone like
Carlos be a part of this team is that I
thought that it's really it was really
important for all of us that if we were
gonna add someone to up to our team that
they bring a unique perspective and I
think that his perspective as a
mexican-american like telling this kind
of story about perception was just so
important and along the way like every
single member of the cast and Jenny and
I kind of soldiers have a little short
telling like how she ended up being part
of this process and I would love for her
to say her perspective which brought
which was very very important to what
the story is about in this case I read
this character and I felt like I can be
observe 'us and the last time I felt
like that was my first series ionically
the l-word a person is so very different
from me but this person is actually very
similar to me
the first thing I wanted to do was take
a meeting with chess Keith and Carlos
and make sure that they were okay with
my way into Val and that was in the
experience of the child of immigrants
and again we don't talk about that at
all but is if there's any is there
anyone here who is an immigrant or the
child of immigrants yes okay so you know
you know that we feel this thing it is a
responsibility to uphold the sacrifices
that our parents have made for us to be
in this country and receive and thrive
within these gifts and that means that
you have to put yourself first in your
own growth and you can be in love with
someone and see that they will hold you
back and have to choose yourself over
your love and that is what I wanted to
make sure they were okay with in and we
were all on the same page and then
that's when I read and ironically I was
in a room of all immigrants and child
children of immigrants when I had that
meeting it was emotional we got a little
teary congratulations on this movie